all right good here we are
Hugo November QA man this month feels
like it has lasted a year it has been it
has been crazy yeah that's all I started
in Chicago did did a know I was in
Chicago in the last last week of October
then I went to st. Vladimir's in
November and gave some talks there which
I haven't put up yet but I will be
putting up soon at least one of them and
yeah a lot of stuff I there was a I
don't know if you all of you I've seen
this there was a Newsweek article on my
Kanye West video which which brought a
lot of strange attention which was fine
which is fine and what else I did the
first interview on think spot that has
ever happened so I so we did that with
Stephen Blackwood if you're on think
spot I think you can access it and yeah
just so much stuff oh also there's Lisa
parrot and a few other people from the
Facebook symbolic discussion group
started a clip channel so I encourage
you all got you guys all to go see that
maybe I can put maybe I can put I don't
know I'm gonna be able to do it maybe
some we can post the link to that in the
chat I don't know I don't think I have
I'm gonna find it right away
but anyways so that happened in November
and yeah just just a bunch of stuff just
a bunch of stuff happening good stuff
and not as good stuff hard stuff to deal
with my house we finally insulated the
basement for the winter and so that
feels really good that that happened and
I'm also started carving quite quite a
bit more now people who follow me on
Facebook and Twitter probably saw that
I've been posting more pictures of
carvings which is which is good so Jacob
Jacob just posted the the clips
in the chat so if you guys want to check
that out and subscribe there that it was
great about the chat and I'm really
excited to see how it's gonna go is that
I do own the chat and but it's--but is
gonna be run by people who by volunteers
people who who want to go into the
videos and find clips and put them up so
for me it's going to be exciting to see
what what in the end what is the thing
that people are are liking about my
videos and so hopefully that'll help me
as well to be able to put up some to put
up some better stuff so alright and yeah
so the the subscribers the subscriber
amount this month has gone up quite a
bit I think because of the Kanye West's
video the Joker video and also because
the rise of Jordan Peterson video video
was number one on at least iTunes in
Canada I know I don't know in the US but
it seems to be doing pretty well and so
I think people are coming in through
that not sure but yeah still though
November is like the worst month because
it's not because it's it's dark here at
like almost like 4:30 and so it just
weighs on you I see I got in this stupid
Twitter fight with Brett Weinstein my
goodness I'm like a child when I go and
I get into these stupid Twitter fights I
I just I just want to slap myself it's
like what am i doing
anyways alright enough for that all
right guys let's go into the questions
okay so oh wait I'm gonna what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna unpin there's a way to
unpin the chat so that I can have it all
the way always up there you do that
so anyways I'm in a strange mood
hopefully I don't fall into rant mode
that's always like my worst my worst
mode alright okay here we go so I'm
gonna start as usual as you guys know
people who give $10 on my on my
different platforms they get to ask
questions in advance and then after that
I look into the the chat and see if
there are super chats there's a lot of
questions
there are a lot of questions I think
soon I'm gonna ask people to in the in
the advance question to just each person
post one because at some point we're
gonna run out of gonna make these three
our streams I don't think I can do that
I know some people do that I don't think
I can alright you go so Joshua the mover
asks silly question but perhaps there's
more to it are their guitars in heaven
musical instruments are worldly things
yes but in making music they serve a
purpose which is intrinsic to being
perhaps this ties more loosely into the
greater subject of technology could you
elaborate I don't know that answer like
yeah I do know how to answer question
like that okay no there are no guitars
in heaven maybe I'm being I'm being okay
let me I'm gonna be technical with you
guys for a few seconds but no there are
no guitars in heaven maybe there are
guitars in the kingdom of heaven there's
quite a difference between the kingdom
of God the kingdom of heaven and heaven
itself heaven is not material there's no
there's no there the kingdom of heaven
is the place where let's say the
spiritual essences meet the
manifestation and so in the kingdom of
heaven I think that the guitar plays
some role it probably does or that
something the night the idea of maybe
not the guitar per se maybe something a
little higher up on the hierarchy maybe
something like stringed instruments
something like that I think probably has
some role in terms of manifesting
something important about pattern and
about about rhythm all these things are
related to so yeah I don't have a
problem with musical instruments but um
there are no musical instruments in
heaven I hope I do understand Josh I
understand what I mean when I say that
they that the difference between heaven
and the kingdom of heaven let's say
alright so Jesse Blaney says hi Jonathan
I loved your last two
that helped us better understand
craziness of the Halloween tradition
I've been reading Stephen King's
non-fiction book Danse Macabre where he
gives Anna dad an anatomy of the horror
genre in the second chapter he lists
that there are three fundamental horror
archetypes the vampire the werewolf and
the thing without a name
aka Frankenstein since you're already
covered the symbology of the vampire in
the video could you share your thoughts
and symbolic symbology of the werewolf
and/or the thing without a name
I've suspicion that the thing without a
name could be the most critical to
understand because often it's a creature
made from our own human devices so for
sure if you take those three categories
there are interesting categories to
understand what the types of monster the
idea of the the the werewolf as being a
hybrid is an important is one of the
most important categories in terms of
monsters the idea of an animal man we it
doesn't necessarily have to be a
werewolf there are all kinds of animal
men there are you know you can think of
fawns in ancient you know in ancient
ideas you can think of centaurs if you
look at if you look at the ancient ideas
of these human-animal hybrids they
usually always represent something
similar a kind of giving into animality
you know and so I think that the
werewolf represents that as well in our
culture in terms of the mods the thing
without a name I think I think that he I
think that he's mixing two things
together there is there is a another
type of monster which is really
important which is the the foreign thing
like the the thing without the name in
the sense of like the the blob or you
know the the idea of a monster that
comes from below you know like like
octopus or a sea monster the Kraken all
these types of monsters that are kind of
like these huge gigantic chaos monsters
or the dragon even as well that kind of
come up and will devour you
that's different from Frankenstein
Frankenstein is a golem really is just
another version of a golem which is a
human a human fabrication which has gone
wrong a human experiment which has gone
wrong and you see that in a lot of
stories especially modern stories the
idea of the human experiment gone wrong
or the you know um you see that in
Marvel Comics and in Indian popular
culture that you know the kind of the
Hulk he's also a human experiment gone
wrong and somebody obviously these mixed
together but I think that hopefully that
answer is a little bit in terms of
understanding I mean he's obviously
Stephen King knows what he's doing
because he's mastered frightening people
so okay so white ear asks what is the
symbolism of the magic mirror in Snow
White the Queen repeatedly asks the
mirror for validation of her beauty it
seems like there may be some parallels
with social media especially Instagram
yeah that's interesting that's
interesting I mean in the way in in a
way the the the mirror the magic mirror
you could see it just as the mirror we
make it magic but in in the sense that
doesn't necessarily have to be magic it
just the mirror that is the mirror
reflects back at you and you see
yourself and and so it's looking into
the mirror is it can be a form obviously
it can be a form of vanity but then it
can also turn on you because as that
vanity can become judgment as you lose
your beauty and so I think that I mean
it makes sense that it's a magic mirror
but it also makes you could imagine that
it would just be a mirror so she looks
into the mirror she sees she's the most
beautiful and then at some point she
looks into the mirror and she sees she's
not the most beautiful
anymore you know and and and she
recognizes that it's someone else
of course the magic mirror tells her
that it's no white but you know she
already knows that it's no white you
know that's why she's so mean to her in
the story is because she knows that it's
no white and so just looking into the
mirror well at some point revealed to
her
at what point that she's lost she's lost
that to Snow White so you can imagine
the mirror just as you can imagine the
mirror as vanity turned against itself
you know as the the reason why she looks
at herself in the mirror yeah ends up
being that which is going to judge her I
don't that makes sense
hope it makes sense there's probably
more to it but that's what I can think
of right now
I mean I'll probably do a video on Snow
White at some point there's so many
things to talk about
it's like an endless thing to talk about
so so I'll probably I'll probably do a
video on Snow White and hopefully I'll
have thought about it more by that time
all right so David fleurs asks what is
your favorite song on Kanye's album I
think it's I think it's that song Sayla
I just really like that I just really
like it I think when the album came out
I hadn't done that in years I hadn't
done it in years where I just had it on
repeat at some point and I was just
listening to it over and over I must
have listened to it like 50 times I
don't know why I mean I do think I know
why I really liked the last part of the
song it feels like a kind of anthem or a
you know a kind of pep talk or something
where he talks about he says you know we
are the we are the youth we have the
power we are the truth like I really
love that part
I just find it just find it it's very
encouraging so you said in your recent
videos oh by the way I hope everybody
saw that Kanye West is doing a opera on
Nebuchadnezzar which is
you can't imagine you know who would you
know when we say symbolism happens guys
it's like could you I could I don't
think I could have figured that out on
my own but it's like when I saw that
Kanye West is doing hey he's doing of an
opera under beacon editor I thought this
is the perfect story it's the perfect
story for now you know like have you can
either the king of Babylon who in his
pride you know makes a statue of himself
so that everybody would worship in and
then finally becomes a beast becomes a
becomes you know falls into a kind of
vest eality bestial mode until he
repents and recognizes the true God it's
like it's a it's a it's a perfect story
it has that you shape it has that fall
into into death moving out into the
margin it has all of it but also it is
so relevant to today in terms of Babylon
as the great [ __ ] and some of the
things that I said in my video but also
this relationship with 666 that I the
aspect of Babylon which is also a kind
of system which encompasses all the
things that should not be part of
society or that should be on the margins
of society and so and so anyways I'm
really looking forward to see when he
comes up with that guy
the Kanye West is like is really as a
tuning fork for reality he seems to be
really tapped in so it's worth it's
worth paying attention to that okay and
then david Flores also asked he said in
one of your recent videos that there's a
legend of King Arthur being a Trojan
could you elaborate on that tale I'd
never heard of it and where can I find
it I've always been partial to our
theory and legend well the idea that
King Arthur comes from Trojan if it's a
it's one of the earliest ideas it comes
from from Geoffrey of Monmouth from his
uh his history of the kings of England
and in that he mentions that
he mentions that Arthur is a descendant
of one of the Trojans but the idea of
the Trojans is really really important
to understand because Rome also saw
itself as a descendant of the Trojans so
you have to you have to kind of
understand the the shift to change from
the Greek world to the Roman world as a
flip I've been thinking about that a lot
quite a bit these days this idea of this
of this flip um and so you go from a
narrative where the Greeks are the
heroes to where the Trojans are the
heroes and then when you Lao read The
Iliad if you read The Iliad you will see
that the Trojans seem much nobler to us
and it's because we're more like the
Trojans even even even today we struggle
to understand Achilles in his 10th
brooding and and complaining that
someone took his sex slave away from him
like it's just harder to understand that
them but the Trojans just have more we
just have more sympathy for them anyways
so so it is it's a very old tradition
and it's definitely worth looking into
Geoffrey of Monmouth's book is
definitely worth looking into guys if
you want to a great book if you want a
great book on legends and helping you
understand what Europe is and what
Britain is and relationship to Europe
and what you know the role that it plays
that book is great you know people have
cast it aside because they say it's just
a bunch of legends but you know that's
why we should look at it all right okay
so let's keep going so why do you to
also ask so many more young adults have
nose piercings today
do you see nose rings as a fashion trend
fad or is there some deeper symbolism at
work thank you sincerely for your work I
don't think the question of nose rings
in is particular in itself I think that
we need to understand the idea of
piercings like the return of piercings
is definitely important and it also it
kind of manifests itself as some kind of
rebellion not so much anymore but a
little bit like a little bit you rarely
see people in their 40s who still have
nose rings once in a while you do but
it's rare it it has to do with you know
it's the same people getting pierced all
over the place you know in our culture
it has it's the same as smoking it's the
same it's the idea of doing dangerous
things you know and and and and doing
things which are different from others
and it and attract attention to you for
sure for sure piercing in general and
wearing jewelry is related to
ornamentation and I've talked about that
quite a bit but I don't think that I
don't think that the nose ring is more
significant than the eyebrow ring or or
the multiple earrings or you know the
tongue ring or whatever like in the lid
like people just pierce of their whole
body now so for sure it it is it it you
can't avoid seeing that it's um somehow
a breakdown of a breakdown of
conventionality you know alright
hopefully that answers that
so sls 94 asks dear Jonathan thank you
for your recent coverage of st.
Christopher and one of your talks it
really spoke to me thank you for the
good work at doing this channel you
played a large part in me becoming more
interested in traditional Christianity
and liturgy I'm not sure if anyone
already asked this in a previous Q&A but
you have any advice as to what sort of
local church I might join being
disillusioned by my own branch of
Protestantism as I do have some issues
disagreement with Catholicism and the
local Russian Orthodox Church's liturgy
is largely and Russian which I do not
speak keep up the good work
look I don't know I mean it'd be
interesting to know where you are in
terms of
you know if it's possible to find an
orthodox church nearby if there are
really no Orthodox churches at all
nearby I would say to look for a at
least look for a church that is
liturgical the difficulty with the
liturgical church especially the
Protestant liturgical churches is that
lets say the Anglicans can sometimes
have a pretty good liturgical structure
but they're so wild they're so crazy
that they're there their thinking is has
gone completely nuts and so it's not
necessarily going to be great for you to
go there but you might be okay just
depends where you are just depends
what's around you
there's also the possibility you can
reach out to someone too there are some
there's some priests Orthodox priests
online that you can that you can talk to
and sometimes they can help direct you
you know in in a direction to find
something um that's that's the best
that's it you know we do with what we
can you know I understand that it's
sometimes difficult and it's hard to
find a good church it's hard to find a
good church for everybody you know where
where it's in a tough time for
Christianity um you know we have to be
the church we always have to tell
ourselves that is that we have to we
have to not just we have to not just
think that we're going to a church and
that church is going we're gonna join
something but we have to become like
it's the only way things are gonna get
better hope that makes sense
all right so Jacob Jacob Russell asks
all right I've been thinking a lot about
the physical manifestations we may use
in our attempt at participating in the
sacred well I can see a meaning behind
many of the things done during a liturgy
or even prayer crossing oneself
frustrations and bowing etc and even the
meaning behind non sacred practices such
as waving to say hi shaking hands or
even flipping someone off I struggle to
understand whether there could be deeper
implications on one's soul if they are
doing
things related to other traditions right
the most obvious example is yoga which
was a practice with with in many Eastern
religions and can still be found being
practiced in the West though arguably a
watered-down version do you think that
there is a valid argument for staying
away from such a physical practice when
it is in a Christian tradition on the
flip of this could anon thieves begin to
align themselves with Christ if they
make the sign of the Cross
even if done in a mocking matter how
does much ignorance or now if they play
in our willing and wanting to align
ourselves with the sacred hope that
makes sense I think it's a great
question
and I think I don't have a clear answer
to you and and it's hard because it's
like I think everybody kind of has a
different a different answer or a
different standard for example I I don't
personally have a problem with people
who do yoga I know people do yoga I
would never do yoga like I would just
would never do that um because it's
funny because one of the reasons why I
wouldn't do yoga is because I it's not
the only reason but one of the reasons
is that I'm pretty sure that the people
are in here in my city who are doing hot
yoga or doing some kind of yoga don't
understand what they're doing and it's
like they're playing with fire and they
don't know what it is they're they're
playing with they don't understand what
it is they don't understand that the
purpose of yoga in India was to was to
bring people towards enlightenment it
was to create spiritual experiences and
so you know it's like it's like I know
I'm not I'm certainly not gonna go to
some class with some 25 year old lady
who had you know who doesn't know
anything about this and his has learned
to do yoga and he's gonna take you on
these exercises and it has no and she
has no understanding of what those are
supposed to really link to to me that's
just dangerous it's just a dangerous
thing but anyways like I'm not saying
that if you go take a yoga class you're
gonna you're going to I don't know
you're gonna be possessed by a demon or
something I don't think it's that simple
I just I just myself have never
I've always felt like it's it's not it's
too weird like for I'll give you an
example though something that I I have
no problem with and maybe some people
would disagree with me is that I have
taken some martial arts classes and if
there was an opportunity like a really
good opportunity I probably would do
that again and because that because
martial arts is also a fighting
technique and because it is although it
was obvious like if you look at kungfu
or if you look at some of the some of
the practices that they do understand
things analogically they understand it
spiritually to a certain extent there's
also the idea that you really do have to
beat the guy in front of you like you
actually have to win the match you have
to learn the Moot like you if you keep
you know if you don't know how to block
you don't know how to block it you know
there's no it's there's also a grounded
aspect to it which seems to make it less
dangerous in my opinion but like I said
that's that's just my standard you know
the idea that that doing like would
someone who's an atheist making the sign
the cross would it may be aligned them
with Christ look I don't know I don't
know one of the things that I that I
know is that my father my father does
this this thing I think it was it called
EMD EMDR something like that it's like a
psychological technique to help people
who are traumatized and he was telling
you that in order to help people who is
traumatized like they have they had to
go back through their memories and and
here they move any moves his fingers
like this and and they have to follow
his fingers and I was like really so
interesting it's like there's actually
something in the brain which is
activated when people follow a certain
gesture of the fingers and so it's just
interesting it like I think that we
don't totally understand how these types
of these types of gestures can have can
have an effect on us and can realign us
as you said now whether or not an
atheist doing that would help them I
have no idea what rather they do that
and other things
all right okay
so Eddie T asks what is the meaning of
Jesus's commandment to the disciples
that they should watch each other's feet
in a way it's like in a way this is the
mystery of Christianity like this is the
mystery of Christianity which is that
Christ both that Christ is both he said
Christ says if you want to be the the
first of these you have to become the
last like if you have to become the
servant of all and it's this idea it's
first of all this idea that there's
actually a link between the highest and
the lowest and it's related to the idea
of ornament that I've talked about to
relate the related the relationship
between death and glory you know I've
talked about this quite a bit as well
and and so there's it's like there's
this relationship between death and
glory so one can be transformed into the
other and it seems that a lot of what
Christ is talking about is how to
operate that transformation how to make
the low how to make the the how to turn
death into glory basically and so and so
for example like if you want to
understand Christ washing his disciples
feet you also have to understand Christ
at the Last Supper giving the food out
he's at the head of the table he is
giving the food out he is he is he is
telling the disciples who's gonna betray
him he's acting as the the king he's
acting as the the one who's giving his
own body out for them to eat it and so
he's in this absolute position of
authority he's he's taking the position
of a god right he's he's he's an and two
right after that moment that's when he
washes the disciples feet so you have to
have those two stories together if you
separate them you
miss out on what Christ is doing if you
only have the washing the feet part you
end up with a inverted hierarchy in the
sense of something like social justice
you end up with something that looks
like these social justice warriors who
who only talk about that who idealized
the marginal who idealized the poor who
idealized
the the who make the lowest the highest
automatically it's like that's not what
Christ is doing it's like crisis joining
he's he's doing these two things he's
he's he's joining them together and and
and that is different and it creates
something very it's difficult to
understand it Christ is really difficult
to understand because his story is too
big and his actions are too big but but
if you want to understand washing the
feet you have to have those two things
together and and like I said if you
separate them that's when you end up
seeing things like you see an excess of
the kingly part in Christianity
sometimes where you know there's an
excess of temporal power and excess of
imposing the this type of excess and
then you have the other excess in in
Christianity which is this this
celebration of the victim you know
excessive celebration of the victim you
would say or or of an upside down
hierarchy something like that and so you
need those two together in order to have
all of reality sorry I'm not giving you
any more than that but these types of
questions man when you ask me like what
does it mean when Christ does this it's
really hard to exhaust that because you
know it's Christ alright okay here we go
alright so we're done with done with the
know the website and so I'm going to
subscribe star here we go alright so
Samuel asks hi Jonathan
I've always wondered about the quote
from Luke where Jesus says father if
you'd be willing remove this cup from me
nevertheless not my will but yours be
done I
was found this to be a mysterious moment
as God the Father and the son are one I
read a little on the subject but many of
the explanations I have heard
essentially say he did not really feel
this as he could never have had any
doubt that and Jesus is acting but this
seemed slightly odd give any thoughts on
this to be honest to be honest I don't I
don't think that Christ was acting I'd
if okay so the way you can understand it
if you understand the idea that Christ
is acting you have to understand it in
the sense that Christ is playing out the
story but you can't understand it as
he's pretending you have to understand
it as he is fully engaged in the story
he's fully engaged right he did suffer
on the cross he didn't he wasn't you
know the God laughing as his body was
dying on the cross he wasn't that's the
Incarnation he wasn't he wasn't being
cynical about what was happening and so
if you if you if you look at that
mysterious moment you have to you have
to kind of understand it as a
manifestation of of Christ's identity in
the sense that Christ like Christ can
only be the logos like he is only the
logos if he submits his self himself to
the Father but he is I'm not saying he
could have done something else but but
but to understand that that is what
makes him the logos is that he is doing
the will of the Father and so and so
that moment is is like playing out
playing out the submission of the son to
the Father the submission not only of
the son but then
ultimately you could say all of creation
and all of us that we also have to die
to ourselves in order to participate in
that process and so it's it's not that
he's pretending but that he's playing it
out completely and fully in the story I
know if that makes sense that's the best
way that I can explain it to my
understanding all right so so Nicola
asks what is the difference between two
icons in the church when it's printed as
high quality poster and the second one
is painted by hand I understand that it
is okay to have printed icons in the
church but I would guess that they have
their limits in terms of where they
could be implemented for instance I
don't think I've ever seen a printed
icon on an icon a status in any of the
Orthodox churches yeah I've seen I seen
printed icons and iconostasis
for sure it's it's a difference of
quality is what it is and it's a it's a
problem of modernity in the sense that
it's a it's it's a problem of having
access to these printed images and they
do the job you know there's there's
nothing theologically wrong or there's
nothing heretical about a printed icon
for sure but they they show you the
problem of Technology right they show
you the problem of what it can do to
tradition because you have to imagine a
world you know because if you see people
using printed icons you have to imagine
a world where everybody uses printed
icons and we don't have iconography
I can ographers anymore so it does it's
not a it's not a living tradition it's
not it's not a living tradition that is
being that is organically existing and
being modified and participating in the
in the church it has become this fixed
thing which is printed out
mechanically and so that is where the
problem arises is that if we if we give
in to printed icons then we're actually
killing the we're killing the the art of
the church in the long term you know
obviously this could never happen but
because it would be heretical to do that
but you can imagine that someone might
be tempted at some point when there's no
no singer to just play you know to just
play it to have music playing like
recorded music while during the liturgy
and they would never do it because it
would be you would actually I don't
think you could even canonically not
have people singing but to me to me the
printed icon is akin to that in the
sense that it's beautiful you know you
look at a printed icon it can be
beautiful it can be probably be a better
icon than you could even get if you got
it painted but it's yeah it's destroying
the art of the church so alright so
Nicola also asked if a man is
symbolically considered to be the head
of the house what would a woman's role
be in that analogy which should be the
heart of the house or maybe even the
house itself yeah I think that I think
that understanding that that the woman
is is in a way the house or the home
gribbit home is a better word than house
that she is the the Knitting of the
private sphere like the possibility of
of the home you could say it's that way
that without the without without a woman
you know a man a man would not have a
home like would not have a would not
have a home and not have a family and so
she is the possibility she gives the
possibility of the family and then and
then the man is seen as the leader you
could say
both are necessary both are really
important you know and it's not I've
been talking about this recently I did
an interview with Benjamin Boyce which I
hope is gonna be made made public where
we talk about this as well the the
importance of the absolute necessity of
the feminine not only in society but
also even in understanding discourse and
understanding how reality lays itself
out you need the opening up of the space
you need the possibility of discourse
before discourse happens before the
actual terms of discourse happen so you
you you absolutely need that to happen
and so that's how you can understand
like in a discourse you would say you
would say that though the feminine is
the possibility of the discourse is the
the frame of the discourse and then the
the masculine would be the direction or
the terms of the discourse itself but
without that first frame without that
first question there's nothing right
there's no there's no there's no family
there's no discourse all right hopes
that me hope I hope that makes sense
all right so Craig Henrik's asks goals
conscious and unconscious manifests the
world to us I noticed that people don't
like to discuss their goals for a
variety of reasons it seems is this
related to the power of the implicit do
we hide these goals in darkness for fear
of our hierarchies in space family
culture spirit because they don't
glorify God they make us feel naked so
like why do people don't like to discuss
their goals because so this is something
very important in terms of understanding
logos let's say our understanding
purpose is that a purpose is on the one
hand your it is letting that which
motivates you or the direction that your
you're aligned with
right and you need that you need you
need that in order to move you need to
have
Talos you need to have a direction of a
way you're going
but that purpose is also ultimately is
your judge it's going to judge you
because once you come to the end let's
say of something that the purpose of
that thing is going to judge you right
so you can think about it just in terms
of race it's like as you're running the
race the end or the the goal the the
finish line that's you're doing
everything to reach the finish line to
reach first like you that's what's
motivating you that's what's making you
go but once the race is finished then
that goal is judging you and is going to
tell you how you did and so I think that
one of the reasons why people don't like
to discuss their goals is that they
don't want to expose themselves they
don't want to expose themselves to the
judgment of the world they don't want
the world to participate in that
judgment if they don't succeed in the
goals that's one the second is also
because the second has a little more to
do with the idea of of the secret like
you said or the idea of the hidden
aspect are the ideal your heart that
your heart which is hidden and that is
also also like has to do with the idea
that there's a fragility in the seed
itself and people would rather with
reason would rather you see the results
of the goal right would actually would
rather than see you play it out rather
than the seed itself because the seed is
very fragile until it has a body so that
the purpose is is nothing until it
starts to have a body and so once you
know like I mean you see it in the
parable of the of this of the seeds
Christ talks about that word talks about
the the the the seeds that were thrown
you know next to the road
they were picked up by the birds you
know the idea also the seeds that that
grew really fast right away and then
they they they died in the Sun it's like
you could see that a related to goals
not just related to Christ himself or to
salvation each goal also has that
structure where it's like the seed is
very fragile unless it finds the right
the right land in which to to body in
which to grow so it's best to have your
goal and to hide it in the earth like a
seed and then wait till it starts to
grow something before you make it public
because if you make it public right away
it can be snatched from you I mean also
just just by people criticizing you just
by you know by you seeing that you're
not accomplishing it there's all these
ways in which it can it can start to not
play out but it's always best to have
people see the results of your goals and
then you know then then they can figure
out the goal on their own they can think
they can see it once it starts to have
body and usually when people start to
have a body like when people start to
manifest their goal then they'll they'll
say it it's like you know it's after
you've lost five pounds that you start
telling people that you know you're on a
diet if you tell them right away you
know then if you fail that's it like
you're gonna get judged alright okay so
done with subscribe start moving on to
patreon patreon is where a lot of the
questions are man I think there's like a
lot of questions alright you go alright
so norm Golding says can you speak up to
the symbolism of Advent wreath and
candles also any recommendations of
things to do not to do during the Advent
season I mean I think the
symbolism of candles let's say are
pretty much always the same just
depending on the circumstance they
usually have to do with they usually
have to do with focusing in terms of you
know you you focus something you focus
your intention on a candle and you light
the candle and then that flame going up
you know is carrying your intentions up
to heaven I mean obviously you know it's
it's a it's a symbolic gesture so you
you you you focus your attention you
light the candle and then that that
candle that flicker becomes a spark
becomes that spark of your intention
which is now being carried up in in a
prayer alright and so that's usually
what candles in the religious sense have
to do but they can also be related to
memory and it's very close like it's
very close in the sense that we light a
candle to remember the dead and I think
that we light a candle also to remember
in the time of Advent the if you see the
wreath and the candle together you can
kind of understand what it's about in
the sense that it also has to do with
this darkening you know I talk about
this all the time in my videos about the
idea that from you know as we move
towards Christmas we're moving towards
the the Solstice we're moving towards
the show the the shortest days and and
into lighting candles in that time has
to do with a kind of preserving of
memory preserving of the memory of the
of light and and a preserving of it's
like almost like a preserving of hope
you could say something like that it's
like also lighting a candle can also be
a sign of hope hope like hope and memory
are related it's weird we rebuilt it too
to think that but hope and memory are
related in the sense that it's it's like
like keeping today that which was you
pass or that which will come in the
future it's like you're keeping it today
you keep your mind you're mindful of it
now and so and so that I think is what
lighting candles are and and so the so
the candle and the wreaths or the
wreaths yeah it seems to have to do with
the idea of something green in a time
where everything's dying like to have
something green that to remember as
you're moving towards the Solstice as
you're moving towards the the towards
death you're you're you're preparing the
notion of this light that's going to be
it's going to come in the darkness that
this this new light which is going to
appear at Christmas um all of these
images seem to be related to each other
I'm sure the wreath has a lot of other
connotations that I'm not that I'm
missing now and that if I thought about
it they would probably come to me and so
what to do not to do during Advent I'm
you know it's I think you have to follow
the tradition of your of your church
they're different people do different
things like in the Orthodox Church
there's actually a fast during Advent
which is not as strict and is not as
practice like I find the Advent fast
very difficult to follow just because
all my you know all my family isn't my
family is and Orthodox and then people
start having holiday season way before
the 24th like they start having parties
and and and and you you were invited and
so you you know you engage with people
more than more important to engage with
people rather than fasting so I find it
I find the fast Advent fast very
difficult the Lent is easier for me at
least but yeah people fast and it's
difficult like even for me like I can
see in my family I wouldn't I wouldn't
try I mean kind of trying with my kids
to kind of remind them that like
preparing for the Christmas season
Advent is is like it it's like a time of
of it's not a time of celebration yet
it's almost like a time of meditate
meditative calling you know of preparing
yourself for the celebration but
everything is all mixed up now so
it's just Christmas like right away it's
all Christmas because we're all
decorating and getting ready so it's
tough it's tough to have actual Advent
practices so if you guys are able to do
it I'd love to hear about it because
seriously I find it difficult to have
Advent practices alright so another
question about Advent as the church
approaches Advent the Magnificat is
recalled and it's similarities to
Hannah's prayer in 1 Samuel looking into
this I saw some church fathers held that
Mary symbolically fulfills the role of
the Ark of the Covenant
what is the Orthodox understanding of
the parallels between Mary and the ark
yeah for sure mary is the ark mary is
very is all the all the places of
epiphany like all the places where God
manifests himself you'll see you people
using Marian imagery to talk about that
in the sense that in the Old Testament
every place of Revelation is an image of
Mary as the ultimate personal revelation
as the bringing of that revelation into
the heart and so not just the art but
the ark the tabernacle the paradise even
the mountain
sometimes the ladder and it's funny
because the ladder seems to be seems you
can understand it as being masculine or
feminine it depends because there's the
things like like there's the road and
there's the way it's like the mother of
God is the road and Christ is the way
you know the mother of God so you can
have the the ladder can be the mother of
god but ascending the ladder and
descending the ladder could be Christ
you know so it's like the every aspect
of Revelation has those two aspects as a
masculine feminine aspect you know the
glory and the arc and the glory and the
tender the tabernacle the temple and
then she's also Jerusalem she's also you
know she's all these things she's also
the earth itself he's you know all the
places of manifestation are related to
the mother of God and really like we man
you were the last week we celebrated the
entrance of the mother of God into the
temple and now staying really paying
attention to some of the readings during
the services and my goodness it's all
there guys it's so amazing like the
services in the church just have so much
to offer I mean it was like she was the
heavenly temple and there was a heavenly
tabernacle and there was all these
things about her it was really is really
wonderful um all right so father Scott
Murray asks therefore brethren since we
have confidence to enter the sanctuary
by the blood of Jesus could you speak
about the symbolism of blood
particularly why the blood of Christ
gives us access to the Holy of Holies
symbolism of garments of skin putting on
death to protect from death seems
applicable but what does that really
mean in this context in this sense in in
Hebrews in Hebrews I think that we
really have to understand the blood of
Christ as purifying agent and so it's
because the blood of Christ purifies
that it gives you access to the Holy of
Holies
[Music]
it's a widest blood purifier well it one
of the reasons is does have to do in the
sense with this with this the the
capacity for liquid to to to cover let's
say and to wash you know so that in that
were washed in the blood of the Lamb
like that kind of imagery like that the
liquid that the liquid aspect is there
to to remove that which is external and
peripheral so it can have something to
do with
baptism in a way in the sense that it's
that it has to do with the liquid aspect
which is just purifying so that's as
much as I'm gonna give you because this
seemed like the symbolism of sacrifice
and the symbolism of blood and these
these types of symbolisms are so old and
so profound that it is extremely
difficult to pierce them you know I've
been thinking about the idea of
sacrifice for 20 years and I don't think
that I totally get it I think that I
understand aspects of it like Mateusz
book has helped me to understand some
aspects of it but I still think that
there are some things that are that are
that are missing but but if you if you
see in in the image of the RET of the
crucifixion you see the blood of Christ
coming down and and dripping on to the
skull of Adam and that seems at least
for sure to be a representation of what
you see here in Hebrews this idea that
by the blood of Jesus you know we are
able to by being covered by his blood
were able to enter into the Holy of
Holies because it because it it purifies
us and it does have to do with death
healing from death for sure but father
and III that it's like you know i reaiiy
found even like there's some text that I
found in Sanger benissa which talked
about some of that stuff talks about the
blood on the on the horn of the altar
and everything and you can see that even
he is like I don't know like he's on the
he's on the verge of going insane it
feels like sometimes and I and it's like
it's it's it's very difficult to pierce
those but uh yeah so sorry I'm not
giving you I'm not gonna be able to give
you any more on that
so yeah we're even of says I've grown up
in a household and culture where people
just
Khristian right now I'm trying to make
my way to the Bible and use you your and
Paul van der Clay's videos almost as
dictionaries because I find the meaning
rather impenetrable otherwise what
advice would you give to someone who has
to encounter the Christian stories and
teachings for the first time thank you
for all the time you spent patiently
explaining symbolism to slowpokes like
me hope you and your family are doing
well umm yeah you know I I understand I
think it's a I think it's I think it's
tough if you if you if you have grown up
in a place where one of the things that
that I would say is for sure I would say
to like if you if you have enough like
let's say this if you have enough
interest to do it I would say to try to
assist to suspend your desire to right
away criticize in the sense that
especially in the Old Testament like you
read the Old Testament stories if you
never had contact with some of those
stories you're gonna flip out because
some of them are wild like just wild as
in while so but you you just take them
into stories like just read them as
stories um and just try to see the
connection between things I don't I
don't have a better advice for you is to
try to see how images repeat in
different parts of the Bible different
parts of the story and for sure I mean
for sure you should look at what the
Church Fathers said you should look at
the different misty goggies that were
written by the Church Fathers which
explain to the the newly converted
Christians what these texts mean like
you know how they relate to Christ how
they all point to Christ and so I would
say that that is something that that can
help you um and you know I mean
ultimately I would say you should go to
church like find a church
and and and the people there will be
very happy to to help you through you
know I mean meet try to get in contact
with with with people that are in a
church nearby you can you can kind of
gauge them too and see if if you know
what kind of wood wood to say what's
going on in that church but I would say
that that being in the community of
people who love those stories will help
you a lot so Ryan Pinkham asks I think
you know I think these are inverted okay
so first question you said you said
something like things started to break
down in the 11th century I would say
12th century can you elaborate on
specific solve what do you mean do you
mean thinkers like saying awesome also
can you recommend some history books
about the Middle Ages Thanks
I mean I think that you know I'm not
someone who likes to put everything in
Aquinas I think for sure akhom is is a
sign that things are not going well and
that lets say that the this the
connection or this the incarnation of
thinking that was present in in the
early Middle Ages and was present in the
Orthodox tradition is starting to kind
of break down I think that you also see
you also see certain things happen in in
the 12th century that are that are wild
like you see the King of France try to
take precedence over his the spiritual
authority of the the Bishop of Rome like
you see him try to to kind of
humiliating him to us to kind of take
unto himself maybe even the power that
the Pope has you know if you look at the
if you look at the arrests and the and
the
the execution of the the Templars you
know by the king of France you can see
that there's this weird desire to kind
of user spiritual authority you know and
I think that that is also that's a
that's a place where you start to see
like this this this competition between
the political realm understand the
spiritual realm and you start to see the
political world started to take over and
you know it's gonna open up the space
for at some point Luther you know
getting the the support of princes in
order to lead political revolutions you
know and so yeah so so I mean I think
that that's that's what happened that's
what started to happen in the 12th
century um and you know and I think that
there's also the plague that played a
huge role also in kind of breaking
things down and yeah all right
so all right and then the other question
has it said one more Sanger Missa taught
a polka tossed assists right I imagine
you don't agree with him why do you
think he came to that conclusion you
know this is the way I deal with this
seriously like this is the way I I deal
with this is that I think that you
cannot you cannot pretend like there
isn't something that there aren't some
pronunciations in Scripture they talk
about suggest a kind of all all so that
all can be saved like st. Paul talks
about that so that all can be saved st.
Paul talks about you know you have this
image of Christ uniting himself with all
of creation that all of creation is
going to be and God will be all in all
do you have all these these you have
certain
pronunciation in scripture and in if you
read in the like for example if you read
in the life of Moses he he doesn't sing
Gregor Nisa doesn't I don't think even
uses the word época tast assists but he
he traces the pattern and you can see
how the whole pattern that he traces
leads to this fully filling up of the
world with with the divine and so he
reads and maximus the confessor is
reading some acts with the confessor
just a few weeks ago and he says you
know that the goal of creation is christ
like the goal of creation is that it
becomes the body of christ that that is
the reason for creation that is the
Telos of creation that's the goal right
and so all of that is there and is real
but there's also another strain which is
which is clear as day which is that
human freedom is is what makes us in the
image of God and therefore it is God
does not violate human freedom and we a
human person can resist transformation
and that's it like a human person can
resist transformation and in that case
you know saying Isaac this year and I
posted something about this few weeks
ago son Isaac the Syrian says you know
the fire of hell is the love of God that
it is it would be unacceptable to say
that the those who are in gain and the
fire are removed from God they are in
God they're there it is actually God the
love of God which is burning them
because God does not force himself on
anybody right in that sense in the sense
of the human soul and sense of the human
person Yunos capacity to to be
transformed you know and so that's that
that that seems those two things seems
to seem to be there like they seem to be
inevitable and so I don't have a
solution I always tell people that you
always need to have you always need to
hold st. John Chrysostom's homily for
Easter Easter Saturday you know the day
that Christ is in the tomb and you and
his homily for Easter Sunday that for
the Prince Paschal homily he has these
two homilies where they're almost like
opposites of each other where on the one
hand he describes the the punishment and
the you know and the falling short of
the grace of God and and and the fact
that that you know that we're not good
enough that all of this you know and
that we need and that there's this this
burning and all of that like he
describes this the sea scenes and then
the next day the very next day he talks
about how you know if you have not if
you even if you have fasted only one
hour you know God opens his arms and
says welcome to the kingdom and it's
like to me you just have to hold those
two together as as something that is not
is not easily resolvable but manifests
two aspects of a reality which is beyond
our understanding
it's as good as it's gonna get
alright okay so normally I'm trying to
explore the story of Jonah in order to
better understand Lois Laurie's The
Giver
I don't have read that the character's
name is Jonas an obvious allusion so I'm
having a hard time with some of the
story though and and I wonder if you can
help why does Jonah run away initially
from the call is this is is his desire
so why does he run away from the call he
runs away from the call because he
doesn't want to be made wrong he doesn't
want God to have mercy on the city so he
doesn't want to go tell the city that
they'll be destroyed because he he
doesn't he doesn't want them to repent
and then it doesn't happen you know
the Book of Jonah is a comedy guys
seriously it is hilarious
do you read the Book of Jonah as a
comedy you will you will laugh as you're
reading it it's like anyways so that's
why I doesn't want to go he doesn't want
to go because he doesn't want he doesn't
want to be made it's pride he doesn't
want to be shown to be wrong
so it's his desire to be thrown
overboard and owning up to
responsibility or just another way of
trying to get away from God through
death um I know I think I think I think
it's I think it is in a way an Owen
owning up to responsibility yeah
but that scene - that scene is really
important it's important in the joke you
understand the joke in the Book of Jonah
you have to understand that scene
because Jonah is on the boat and the
pagans are there right there they're not
they don't believe in the One God they
have all their gods and their praying
their gods and nothing's happening and
and Jonah is come to them and he's like
you know you need to throw me a boat
over board and they don't want to
they're like no no no we don't want to
throw you overboard you know and he's a
foreigner to them so he's like he
doesn't want he doesn't want they don't
want him and they're pagans they don't
want him to be thrown overboard even if
he's responsible for his for the sin
that that is bringing about this this
calamity on them and so do you need to
see that as a as a mirror of when Jonah
goes to Nineveh and he wants them to be
punished and doesn't want them to repent
right he's angry because the people they
never repent and God big and God saves
them and he's annoyed he's like I knew
it I knew you wouldn't destroy the city
you know and so it's like you have to
see those two next to each other or else
you don't get the joke
anyways alright let's see what else we
got in terms of Jonah so what does it
mean for Jonah to be angry with God at
the end about the plant bringing eat
I mean that's that it's the same place
the same play it's like it's like Jonah
wants God to destroy the city because he
doesn't want to be made wrong he doesn't
like the idea that he's a prophet and
he's going to tell them that God's gonna
destroy the city and then they repent
and then it doesn't happen and then he
looks like an idiot it's like he wants
God to destroy the city you know because
it makes him look bad
that's just a because of his pride and
so then he God doesn't destroy the city
and so he's like annoyed and he goes out
into the desert and then God makes this
plant to grow to give him shade like
it's kind of like a city then he is
something around him to protect him and
then that that that plant dies and then
Jonah's like ah you know kill me and
this is horrible this is the worst thing
ever you know it's a joke the whole
thing is hilarious and it's like it's
the worst thing ever but he just wanted
God to destroy an entire city and now
because he didn't get his plant he got
his planned and then he lost it now he's
he he wants to die and it's the end of
the world
so so it's it's all about these it's all
about these relationships between
different things like you how one looks
like one is showing the opposite of the
other in order to make to make you show
how it's a funny situation I mean
there's it's not just funny it also
shows a very important aspect of reality
all right so what does it mean for
people to not know the difference
between their right and their left hand
you know that is something that I have
been thinking about that phrase and in
the Book of Jonah something that I've
been thinking about for 20 years
seriously at least 20 years and and to
be honest I don't I don't think I
totally have an answer to that I'm
probably gonna be making some videos at
some point about that question of right
and left hand and hopefully I'll build
up enough stuff to be able to talk about
that phrase in
book of johna but to be honest that is
one of my opinion that is one of the
most mysterious one of the most
mysterious sentences in in in scripture
to me at least
um okay so I'm trying to make some
connections norm grown a ask another
question I'm curious to know what you
think the seed is like Christ whereby it
needs to die and fall away from the tree
away from the center in order to be
reborn this can only happen though away
from the center from the tree otherwise
it dies in the shadow of the bigger tree
this is similar to how children need to
move away from the center who need to
let their childhood identity die off and
become reborn but only if they move away
from the center from the parents I
wonder then if this is the kin 2j VP's
notion of rescuing your father from the
underworld where the child becomes a new
center starting a family so that the
cycle can continue not sure how much
sense this thread is making I don't know
even that is related to Jordan's rescue
from the underworld but when it's
related to the the balance of unity and
multiplicity it's related to the the
idea that for anything to have an
identity it has to on the one hand
beasts the same as something and on the
other hand be different from something
you you can't have two things which are
exactly the same because then there
would just be one thing like they have
there has to be difference between two
things even that share the same identity
like two dogs are two dogs but they're
not the same dog because then there
would just be one dog there they had two
dogs and so there has to be difference
and so in order for the world to exist
there always has to be a play between
one and many between identity and
difference you know between yeah between
Center and periphery between all these
things and so the idea of the the idea
of the the seed that moves away from the
tree and has to move a certain distance
in or
to be able to find life that it has to
do with that hope that makes sense
all right so small about asked since
symbolism seems to be everywhere a
different scale I was wondering if you
ever noticed the symbolic meaning in the
gender of French nouns hmm
for instance I heard you mentioned once
that the church was symbolically
feminine as you already know every
native French speaker already knew that
PS I know the context matter and that
something can be seen symbolically
simonin or masking in different levels
of analysis nonetheless my question
stands I think you know I think that I
think that it wouldn't be probably worth
thinking about that to be honest I've
never put any effort into it and I think
that I think that it could it could
maybe have some gives you some fruit it
could also lead you on a very strange
path which which would which might be
just nonsense
like but it would be worth thinking
about it like I think that you'll be
interesting to make a list of things
that are let's say traditionally
associated with feminine and things that
are traditionally associated with
masculine and see if you can find a
pattern there I've never done it I mean
I don't think it would be stupid to do
that I think it would be dangerous to
try to stretch it sometimes and to try
to like find really weird reasons why
they connect but yeah I don't know like
I never I'd to be honest I've never
really thought about it
but it would be worth it would be worth
thinking about so a gars momís asks what
would you say the symbolic meaning of
christ being a carpenter um that's a
good question hey Garth well he's the
son of a carpenter it doesn't say that
he is a carpenter is this in the sense
of he's being the adopted son of Jonah
of a
Joseph my goodness my mind just went
blank there for a second now but he is
related to carpenter and in this in the
scripture there's a place where the
Pharisees that's where you find out
where the Pharisees say that he's the
son like you know who is the son of a
carpenter and I think it's important I
think it's important and it wouldn't be
in Scripture if it was important and I
think that it has to do with the the
saving of Cain there's a lot of things
about Christ which are a restoration of
obtain one of the things is the idea
that Christ is the firstborn that is
extremely important because it the Bible
do you have this idea that the firstborn
is the most important but it never
happens it's always it's always the
second board it's always you know it was
the second born that's the second born
or somewhere somewhere in the smallest
or somewhere someone lower down the line
it's it's always it's always Jacob it's
always Joseph it's always David it's
always you know it's always the little
one and so I think that and and it's
able to and I think that Christ is the
firstborn so because Christ is the
firstborn he he takes upon himself the
symbolism of the symbolism of Cain and
that is why Christ converts Rome I think
and that's why Christ is a carpenter a
techne you know a Tecton he artisan
someone who builds things like the
descendants of Cain built things built
the first cities and develop technology
and in here that's why
crisis described as an agricultural list
you know all these images of seed all
these images of the harvests all of
these images are all related to
agriculture and not only so Christ is
both a shepherd and a farmer it's like
so he's Cain and Abel Christ both Christ
gives bread and wine and he gives flesh
and blood so he gives both the sacrifice
of Abel and the sacrifice of Cain he
gives both sacrifices at the same time
so he's actually uniting Cain and Abel
together in a new Adam and that's what
Christ is and so the idea that he's a
carpenter I think has to do with this
saving of Cain you know I hope that
answers that all right let's see oh
there's more there's more there's more
okay so Taylor Wilson asked if the Bible
Christianity is properly viewed through
a symbolic frame then what is there to
stop it's symbolic equation with other
religions or texts there are many parts
of that of the doubting teaching for
example which parallel with Christ when
he says he is the way the truth and the
life how do you stop making a maps of
meaning Universal universalism out of
Christianity and should you um I don't
have a problem with I I don't have a
problem with the aspects of other
traditions that are good like I don't
there are a few things like there there
are a few things one is that the world
the world cannot be completely in
completely in darkness because it would
cease to exist the world cannot be
completely disconnected from logos
because it would cease to exist the
world is always connected to logos and
so you see the D D you know st. Justin
Martyr talks about the logo spermatic
owes the idea of the seed of logos which
is planted in people from the beginning
of the world which is which is there
which is what is what holding the world
together and so we shouldn't be
surprised when
see when we see in other religions or
another tradition things that reflect
that it's not it's not odd it's not
strange it's so that shouldn't be
surprising but it also certainly
shouldn't encourage up to become
syncretic and to kind of mix things
together and to practice different
aspects of different religions and and
to do all that kind of stuff because
that's just chaos like it doesn't it
doesn't it doesn't help you you know and
so I think but I think that it can be
useful like I don't I I don't feel
threatened by other religions I don't
feel threatened by my Asian religions or
Hinduism is like when I hear people talk
about you know advice Vedanta I find it
extremely fascinating and I and I'm
trying to understand and I'm trying to
see like how can it help me understand
my life and understand the world but I
do that always in the light of Christ
like I do that knowing that I am
attached to Christ and that I am a
Christian I'm not a Hindu and I'm not
Muslim and I'm not something else I am a
Christian and so it's like that's what I
am and that's my that's the path that's
the path like I don't there is no other
path you know so I don't know if that
makes sense I know that like sometimes a
lot of people struggle to understand me
because they either want to say that I'm
some kind of universities or not or that
I'm a relative as I'm not I don't I do
completely practice Christianity and
believe in Christianity but I also don't
think that everything that is not
explicitly in Christianity is evil and I
don't see how a traditional Christian
can think that it's it's absurd because
you know we use the words of the Greek
philosophers we we use terms that were
there in in other religions like we you
know some of the titles for the mother
of God are titles that were given to
ancient goddesses like all these these
things are there and and they shouldn't
bother us
um yeah so you know IIIi just I just
hope that people can understand the
difference between being able to see
that which is good and what is outside
from you and making it equal to you and
want and and and thinking that you can
just pick and choose hodge podge from
everything in order to kind of create
you know some religion in your own image
yeah all right okay so drew McMann asked
if all things are being worked for good
he would follow that every tragedy is
ultimately good if we are seeing the
world properly through this lens we
should never be without joy is sorrow
and suffering just a product of not
seeing the world properly or are we
actually seeing it correctly and sorrow
is justified or is there something off
with my logic there's there's a there's
a term that people use in the orthodox
tradition which is joyful sorrow and
there's there's an idea that in in some
sense you can reach a stand you have
these saints that have the gift of Tears
they call it where the saints cry all
the time
and this gift of Tears is in a way a
kind of infinite compassion where you
you actually cry as you see the
suffering but that also that compassion
also becomes the source of a like an
unbounded joy or an unbounded
peacefulness and so i think
I think that we do need to mourn for
that which which for people who died we
need to mourn for the difficult things
that we need to cry with those who cry
but in doing that is also how the good
comes out of it like compassion is also
the manner in which good manifests
itself in tragedy and so it's the very
it's the very way that that it happens
it's the way that God used one of the
ways that God uses to bring good out of
bad is through compassion and to our
compassion so how that make sense
all right guys man we got through the
got through the questions I still need
to now I still need I still need to
check into the super chats and see what
happened there so I've been paying a lot
of attention to I haven't been paying a
lot of attention to the chat I've been
looking a little bit in there but not
too much so let's see what we got here
okay so we're not so many sweet chats we
can start okay so so I'm going to start
with the mad truth good to see you
happy that you could actually post your
chat you're a super chat for ten pounds
he says Paul says the wife should be
submitted to her husband
why should a sinful human submit to
another is this not sexist and if this
idea is fundamental to the West are
feminists not correct we live in a
patriarchy why should a sinful
in submit to another that's an
interesting it's an interesting question
it's funny because I never thought about
it because when I think of the idea that
a woman should submit to her husband
when i see that in paul i i i never see
it as an isolated thing it's not like
women have to submit to their husbands
and that's it no you have to submit to
the people above you like you have to
submit to your boss to your to your
father you have to submit to your - to
the judge the police officer - to those
who have authority over you right so
it's not it's not it's not just the
image of the the family and the and the
woman submitting to her husband is is
only one aspect of that and it's not
only about it's not only about like the
feminine submitting to the masculine
because you know if you if you if you
encounter a female police officer you
should submit to her GA if you if you
were in the Middle Ages and you had a
queen or a lady then you would have to
submit to her because she would be above
you in the hierarchy and and then that
would just be that would you know like
it would just be part of reality you
know by submitting to something above us
we we learn - we learn to discipline our
passions we learn to not give in to all
our whims and all our all our little
thoughts and all our little desires we
have to learn to to discipline them and
so so it's important to learn to submit
to someone who's above you like as a
child you learn to submit to your
parents because you you you learn to to
let's say hone yourself in a manner and
not be out of control and so
the idea is I've talked about this
before it's like a let's say a police
officer that's corrupt and is taking
drug money you if you are speeding if
you're of speeding and that police
officer stops you and you were speeding
and he gives you a ticket yourself to
take the ticket because the the
authority figure represents a higher
order than himself as well so if you
look at the image of of in in Scripture
of it says that the wife has to submit
to her husband it's like he's relating
that also to Christ it's like like as
the church has to submit to Christ and
the husband has to submit to Christ
right it's not just it's not doesn't
just stop there and it's like it's not
just that the wife has to submit your
husband with that husband has to love
his wife so it's one those two things go
together it's not just one it's like the
husband s love and the woman has and the
wife has to submit that's how it's
presented in in st. Paul and so and
that's the same structure as you facing
the person above you your priest your
bishop your boss your you you have to
learn to submit to that which is above
you and if you're above someone else
then you have to learn to love that
person and take care for them and to
take care of their needs and it's like
everybody is always below someone and
above somebody so yeah so I think that
that's that's the best I can do my
friend
so Richard Roland asks could you ask
about talk about the symbolism of saints
who go to odd places to pray Stylites
st. govern st. Seraphim praying on the
rock so the I mean tolls the
understanding let's say the symbolism of
asceticism in general the idea of
removing yourself from normal life or
removing yourself from
your regular world in order to be able
to pray you know and it's to be honest I
mean it's no different then it's it's
not that different then when you're
reading a book or you're doing your
homework or you're working on something
and you want people around you to shut
up because they're distracting you you
know it's mostly that it's it's it's
that the world if you're trying to be on
a path of let's say of acquiring of
going up that the latter of virtues of
of ascending the spiritual ladder there
isn't there is one aspect which is that
you have to be able to get rid of the
distractions get rid of the things that
are pulling you apart so that you can
truly become you can truly enter into
the heart you could say and so
asceticism is mostly about that and
extreme asceticism is an extreme version
of that and there's also an aspect of
asceticism which is that when you it's
like fasting it's like when you fast
with you with what you're doing is
you're you're revealing your passions
because it's like you know it I mean it
it's like someone who says you know I'm
not I don't need to drink like I could
stop any time you know until you take
the drink away from them then when you
take the drink away from them then they
realize that no they can't stop that
actually they're hooked on this thing
and so one of the reasons for asceticism
is that as well
you know it's like to reveal your
passions and so the extreme aesthetics
they're doing it in an extreme manner
where even they they're trying to be
able to not be distracted by pain not be
distracted by physical comfort by hunger
by thirst by all these bodily things
that are not bad in themselves they're
there's nothing wrong with them but they
they can be a distraction they can be
they can't pull your attention
and so that's why I think it's that's
the the best way I can explain that
all right so Stephen Anderson for gays
$5 Thank You Stephen
dead frogs dead frogs for five us
feeling dollars that I fell
psychologically from what I perceived as
King to lover I burnt dude I'd no idea
what you're talking about now attempting
a great work
any advice how to get to magician I
should not have read that sorry dead
frogs
alright so Thomas for five dollars said
hi Jonathan I should read these before
weeding them out loud my goodness hi
Jonathan can you speak to what's
motivating the rise paganism occult and
what the best way to react reach those
people might be I mean I think that I
think that one of the reasons why people
are interested in paganism and the
occult is because Christianity has
become so milquetoast and boring and and
pathetic right it's like the deep
spiritual aspects that the deep symbolic
connections that the powerful cosmic
vision all of this stuff in Christianity
like no one knows about it anymore and
so when someone who's looking for
something that is that is beautiful and
powerful and coherent and and and and
isn't just this mundane you know just
this mundane go to church once a week
sing songs and and feel good and go back
home you know it's like they they they
don't want that and so I have a lot of
sympathy for people who are attracted to
that stuff because I think that their
motivation is to find deep connections
and to find this this this cosmic vision
and all of that so I think the best way
to reach people like that is to
understand that Christianity what
Christianity has into to understand the
cosmic vision that Christianity offers
and to understand
how connected everything is and how
powerful the the the cosmic vision of
the logos and how it manifests itself in
the world is and you know how symbolic
Christianity is I think that's the best
that's the best way like I know that I
have some some neo-pagans that follow me
like some some Nordic type guys who are
into the Nordic gods and and I know that
there's also kind of new agey people
that follow what I'm doing and and I
think the reason why they do is because
they're hungry for those connections or
hungry to see things make sense and so
it's like I have a lot of sympathy for
them I mean I think I think they're
wrong I think they're wrong and the
reason why I think they're wrong a great
reason is that a lot of the stuff is
that the neo-pagans especially it's just
made up it's it's not it doesn't go deep
at all it's it's a it's it's all kind of
a modern reinvention and it's improvised
and it doesn't have the deep roots that
they think it does you know I once met a
druid and my goodness he was like he was
telling me that he was a druid and you
know I kept asking questions and asking
questions and asking questions like
where does it come from is was there
transmission is there a transmission of
druidic nuk knowledge from the you know
from the time of Caesar you know really
and then you keep prodding and prodding
and then at some point you know they
just he just admitted that it was all
pretty much made up it was all new and
it was all kind of made-up thing it's a
bit of young in a bit of this and a bit
of that it's like yeah that's not that's
not cadets that's not gonna hold guys so
yeah all right
so David Markham asked how can I contact
you to invite you to speak at an Antioch
Antiochian Orthodox event you can you
can just write me an e-mail email is the
best way to reach me if you're looking
for my email you can find my email on my
carving website patio carvings dot-com
and my email is there I don't I don't
put it out on my YouTube videos or
whatever but if people really want to
find me that is the best way to contact
me so Ria's 125 says I'm a novice priest
in the shingon tradition Japanese
Vajrayana Buddhism what is your opinion
of other spirit radition skin Buddhism
Christianity coexist thank you I think I
gotta answer that question before all
right I think that I think that there
are places that I think there are places
where there are connections and those
connections are real i think that i
think that that which holds the world
together holds the world together and
and and hold the world together
everywhere and so and so i think that
that there are that there are definitely
powerful things to be found in all the
authentic religions you could say not so
much I'm sorry but not a lot of the the
New Age stuff is really just just
horrible but but let's say and all the
the kind of more traditional religions I
think that there's something that can be
that can be found there but I do think
that ultimately I mean I do think that
ultimately Christianity does present
itself as a a a final revelation as a
total revelation you know and so and so
I and so I don't think that Christianity
could ever like let's say Hinduism for
example which just kind of sees
everything as you know as a
manifestation of of some aspect of
reality and and it's all good you know
it's I and it's okay and it's there's
this variability I don't think that
Christianity is compatible with that
but in the end I mean I do but I also do
think that I think Christians are meant
to love their neighbor and to you know
and to treat others as they wanted to be
treated and so you know I don't think
that excuses some of the violence that
Christians have wrought upon the world
and some of the let's say some of the
colonizers and their their kind of
attitude of imposing I don't think that
excuses that in any way all right let me
refresh this and see okay so evolving
for $12 asks send you Ginetta I see
you're French
what is the symbolic significant of
Johnny Tran Petersen only being able to
eat beef dude I don't know that there's
definitely something going on like I
have to admit I have to admit that I do
think that it is meaningful I don't I
don't totally understand it I think it's
more than just a physical thing for sure
there's more than just a physical thing
and it and it has to do seems to have to
do with the role that he's playing in
terms of being this this kind of noble
pagan or this kind of transitional
figure but I'm not gonna give you any
more than that cuz I don't I don't think
IIIi have thought that I'm not I don't
think it's a silly question but I don't
think I completely understand it so
Jonathan are $5 says any suggestions for
a single person in a congregation and
they're the only one their age group
yeah that's tough that's tough I
understand your pain I think it depends
what age you are I think that if if
you're at an age where you're wanting to
meet people and you're looking to get
married I would say that you need to not
get stuck in your congregation and and
you need to start to to kind of look at
other churches or to try to see if there
are ways to meet other Christians so
that you can find someone in terms of
the idea just depends also on what age
you are
so Jonathan also says should someone
consciously seek to embody a specific
type of symbolic manifestation ie the
fool no I don't think so I think that
that you should always look to embody to
be an image of Christ and I think that
if you end up if you end up manifesting
a specific aspect of Christ then that's
gonna just happen on its own just
because of who you are and so but I
think you should always look to Christ
as as the ultimate pattern I would say
so what is so sin our D'Oench asks what
is the meaning of the mudras as this I
don't know what a mudra depicted in your
icon carving which are quite similar to
Mudros depicted in Eastern religions you
guys who knows what a Mudder is is it a
halo is that what it is alright here I'm
gonna oh it's that it's that it's like a
blessing it's like a sign of the hand
it's a gesture um yeah okay um well
there are different types of gestures in
icons and they they mean different
things but mostly what they mean and I'm
gonna put out a talk very soon that the
talk that I gave at Saint
is this question in a question one of
the questions mostly what they mean is
direct influence that's mostly with what
it means in the sense that you have
usually the thus the thus the hand
gesture will be done with the right hand
and the left hand will be holding
something a book a or will be covered
sometimes or will be holding a scroll
and so it's it has to do with with
direct influence and indirect influence
or authority and power
the idea of direct authority so it's
like Christianity so the let's take
Christ's blessing and holding a book is
the idea that Christ both has authority
and power that is he both can do
something directly like like bless or
curse or answer all these things but he
also has the earthly power you would say
he also has the text he has the
traditions he has the capacity to to to
to affect the world in that way and so
so in so in Christianity you have the
bishops let's say who have who have
where you have the spiritual lineage
which is the direct authority of bishops
and priests and everything who have the
capacity to to bless and curse and
everything and then you also have the
Bible the liturgy the texts all these
external things so you have the internal
and the external the direct and the
indirect that's something like that but
my the talk will come soon so if you
want more on that you can you can find
it and you can also look on the Orthodox
Archdiocese of articles on the left and
the right-hand and in that I talked
about these end gestures and I also
talked about the left on the right hand
in in general all right let's see God
all right so eleanor's asks what is the
symbolic significance of Kuna al
well I mean it's just it's just it's
just it has to do with not trusting
Authority I talked about I did a video
on on on conspiracy theory or
conspiracies and and I think that it has
to do with the fact that one of the
signs of a breakdown of a society or
something is that we don't trust the
narrative we don't trust the narrative
that we're getting anymore
and I think that for Chan cuing on this
idea of these alternative meaning makers
all have to do with this image that the
world that the narrative or the identity
of our nation's is fragmenting and we
don't trust the people that are there
that are supposed to be there to to care
for us that are supposed we don't trust
our authorities anymore and that's a
sign of breakdown and I think that
people who go to cue anon that's that
seems to be what it is and also it's
like a weird spirit it has a weird
spirituality to it I haven't really
followed it very carefully because I
honestly I I feel I'm kind of put off by
that kind of stuff it feels a lot of it
feels like it's it's also trying to
affect reality kind of Nostradamus style
you know give these obscure
pronouncements yeah that's what I see
but like I said I really have it I
haven't followed it close enough to
really be able to tell you so be strict
asks are superheroes considered some
form of modern mythology given how
prevalent it is in film and gaming
nowadays pushing the hero's journey
narrative I think it's I think it's an
attempt to manifest some aspects of that
I think it's lacking but I think I think
it's not totally lacking there are some
interesting aspects about it
the things that we're seeing now in the
in the superhero genre I like you see it
with the Joker movie and you're seeing
it with with Oh like the Batman movies
and is that you you have a mythology you
really have like a character and you
have basic storylines and then you have
variations which appear and manifest
different aspects of the character that
are possible so it's like you have that
you have a just a very simple character
and then you have all these different
versions of the same story that appear
because ancient mythology wasn't what we
find in texts it was there were all
these variations and so you would have
if he went to a certain area they would
have different stories and then even in
time they would have different stories
and so there were all these different
these variations on the same characters
and I think that that's something we're
seeing happen with superheroes which is
interesting kind of interesting to see
that so you have a simple character like
the Joker very basic but then you then
you have everybody giving a take on the
Joker and and so it shows you how
there's an identity which joins them
together then there's also this identity
is strong enough to handle like a
multiplicity of different types of of um
of realities and so I do think that I do
think that it's playing a part similar
to what mythology was playing before
there is a difference of course which is
that you can't engage in it really like
it's not your story they're not you know
the stories of the ancient gods or the
demigods of the heroes it was always
your story it was your ancestors your
and and you were a you were a descendant
of this like you were you were the you
were the result of them you know no
matter how you see it you know you were
a result of the Trojan War you were a
result of the the bad of the fight
between the gods you were a result of
the mythological stories but that is
something that you don't find in
superhero stories and and also superhero
stories are
and they're they're owned material their
their copyrighted their their you know
the only way you can participate really
in superhero stories ins is by merch and
there's it's not totally there's nothing
completely wrong with that either
there's nothing we're all the bank merge
so there's nothing wrong with with
wanting to engage in a story that way
but I think that we have to be careful
we have to be able to see the difference
see the difference between what ancient
mythology the role it was playing and
and in these superior stories so Jamie
Day asks $5 how can someone motivate
themselves to love God more than a
passion which pulls his attention so
prayer is the way that the fathers talk
about that is there even is this idea
that you really can't like you you
really can't motivate yourself to love
God more than a passion right you you
have to depend on God for that and so
there's almost this idea that that even
if you don't feel the love or you don't
feel this this desire for God that if
you if you have a prayer discipline then
that will they'll kind of spark like
it's like you know it's like a it's like
starting a run push start a an old car
you know it's something like that and so
so the father's they talk about reading
the Psalms reading them out loud praying
the Psalms is a good way to kind of melt
the heart you would say um and I you
know going to church
the singing hymns you know music is also
a way to kind of to melt some of the
some of the the passionate element of
yourself
um yeah
think that that's the the best way going
to confession is a good way also to help
you because it forces you to face your
passions and and then also talking about
it with someone you know and being
encouraged by other people is also a way
for that to happen but I don't think I
don't think that you can just motivate
yourself to love God more than a passion
you have to go about it through others
through a more roundabout way all right
guys
yeah we met almost two hours this I
think this has been the longest Q&A
since the beginning so guys thank you
thank you for coming on and thank you
for everything thank you for for getting
involved in the discussions thanks to
the moderators to Jacob I don't know if
Christian chat is there thanks also to
Gregory - who runs the Facebook group
and - Lisa who's running the clip
channel and to all the people that have
just been awesome
and involved and excited about symbolism
you guys you guys keep me going so so
yeah so stay tuned
I my next video is going to be an
analysis of Tim Cook's speech at the ADL
because because I bought it in my video
on the 666 and and I realized that I
wasn't clear enough about why it's
connected so I need to kind of do an
analysis of that which is gonna be fun
and and yeah and and also for the patron
only video I kind of changed my mind
this month I was gonna do a video on on
witches but I'm gonna what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna put up a video that I did
in a private discussion with some of
what some of the people I talked to
every month and it's it's I wanted to
give you guys a glimpse of like the edge
of symbolism and in this discussion that
I that I did you you really see me like
struggling with with some of these ideas
and trying to understand them and and
it's like it's it's almost like it's
like you're in the laboratory with
me trying to understand things and I
thought that that might be that might be
fun maybe a bit disconcerting to some
people but but I'm gonna try it out and
see how people react to that so guys
thanks a lot and and looking forward to
seeing all of you next month
bye bye